There are different kinds of polyglots.
There are polyglots who like
to read and listen
and get into the culture
of different languages.
And then, there are
the irrepressible travelers,
extroverts who naturally, quickly learn
to speak a variety of languages
comfortably and are very enjoyable
to be around.
One of these is my next guest,
Gabriel from Brazil.
I'm sure you're going to find
this interview very interesting.
Gabriel, nice to see you again.
Likewise, Steve.
It's a great pleasure.
And it's been so long since the last time
we got together in person, it's crazy.
And we got together in person, because you,
for a lot of time, lived in Vancouver.
We used to see each other in Vancouver.
And now, I believe here, in Paris.
And your origins are from Brazil, and so,
you are quite a globe trotter,
as well as an accomplished polyglot.
What I want to talk to you about today
is something that I was thinking about.
As I was actually doing some Danish,
and then, I said,
"Okay, now I got to talk to Gabriel
in Portuguese."
And I never did much in Portuguese.
I'm gonna be really bad.
And then, I said to myself,
"So, for those of us who would like
to explore different languages,
how do we maintain them or do we even
worry about maintaining them?"
"And to what extent do we lose them?"
And that's your thing.
And you speak, I don't know,
10 to 12 languages or so, right?
At varying levels, or is it more?
Well, I would say 11.
At 11, that I would say-
I would be comfortable to say that
I came close to fluency, at least,
or I was fluent at one point or another.
And I've dabbled in a lot more.
But I don't really count those languages,
because, you know, just like-
In many of them, I just reach maybe A2.
Or maybe B1.
And in a lot of them, I'm still at A1,
I just got a taste of the language.
And I put them aside in order to focus
on the languages that are more comfortable.
So, I would say about 11.
Okay, so, would you agree that,
to learn a language to the level of A1,
or A2, or B1, or as you put it,
to taste the language,
is an activity that is well worthwhile?
For me, it has been.
It's always been really fun
to just get started.
Specially because one of the main reasons
why I do this is to interact with people.
So, go to international parties,
say a few things in whatever language.
For example,
Japanese is a language that I love,
that I want to learn seriously
in the future,
I think I may have reached
the equivalent of A2, right?
But I'm aware that to reach fluency,
that's going to take,
you know, a lot of time and dedication,
and it would take me years to accomplish.
So, it's something that I put aside,
because I want to get to the equivalent
of C1 in Mandarin before I do that.
But it's really rewarding, anyway.
It's fun to just be at A1 or A2 in Japanese
just to say and understand a few things.
And I really like anime.
So, I like to watch anime
and just understand some things.
And it's all fun.
I mean, I think that's
an important message.
If people learning languages are exploring
two or three or more languages
feel that if they don't achieve B2
at least, then somehow, they're a failure.
I think that's a very bad way,
a very sort of-
I would say a discouraging way
of looking at things.
Even in those languages
that I never got very far in,
I obviously know a lot more about
those languages,
have a better sense of those cultures,
than if I had never, ever looked
at the language.
So, I think it's well worthwhile,
you know,
even getting to that limited level
in a language.
And then, if that spirit moves,
you just move on to something else.
- Yes.
- Is that kind of your approach?
Absolutely.
I think it's so cool to get
a taste of the language, right?
Just like you said before.
There are languages that I dabble in,
a lot of Slavic languages like,
Czech, Croatian, Serbian, as well as-
Not right now,
I'm actually doing a 30-day challenge
to learn as much Ukrainian
as I possibly can.
And it's really cool, right?
Specially since I speak some decent
Russian, it makes it easier.
And it's really interesting to see
all the differences.
And you start understanding a bit more
of all of them at once in a way.
So, when the languages are connected,
it's really fun to do that.
But yeah, absolutely.
I agree with you that it's all fun.
Now, here's another sort of issue.
And that is, do you do anything special
to maintain your languages?
Not the ones that are A1,
I find those the quickest to fall away.
But once you're almost at a B2 level,
do you do anything special
to maintain them?
I would say so, but-
You know, there are languages
like German that I reached C1.
I don't think I reached C2 in German,
just because I haven't really needed it.
So, I just prefer to focus on different
languages and try to get to B2.
So, I go through phases in which
I just neglect German,
and I don't get a lot of exposure.
So, I do try to get some exposure,
and eventually,
from doing videos in the streets of Paris,
I meet German people, so I talk to them.
And I know I may interview them.
So, it's like a nice way to just try to,
you know, keep it going.
But since it's a high enough level
of German,
I can just basically put it aside,
forget about it for a while,
and I won't forget that much, anyway.
But I'll still be far from where I was
when I was dating a German girl.
I was going to Germany all the time,
and reading a lot of Nietzsche
and Kafka in German, right?
Okay, let me say a few things
to those people listening or watching,
who don't know what B2, C1, etc. means.
Essentially, A is beginner.
B is intermediate.
C is advanced.
And each one of those is divided
into A1-A2, B1-B2, C1-C2.
And this is the common European framework
which sort of tries to establish
what your level in the language is.
I think most of us who say,
"I speak this to a B1 or B2 level."
Have never been tested,
I have never been tested.
However, it's a handy way of describing
what you think your level
in the language is
or your level of confidence,
of your ability in the language is.
I think- Certainly, that's my case.
I don't know, have you taken tests
to confirm that you're B1 or B2?
For French, I got the
Diplôme approfondi de langue française.
I got the B2 back in 2011.
Okay, so you have taken the test.
I have taken that one and I passed.
With a terrible grade, by the way,
but I passed.
But I'd say that-
So, in French-
You know, right now, I'm living in Paris,
so I'm definitely C1.
I don't know, I don't think I'm at C2 yet.
Because I've also not been focusing
that much on French.
I've been focusing more on
Mandarin and Russian.
And right now, for instance,
I'm entirely focused on Ukrainian.
But, for example, for German,
I would be very confident that I'm at C1.
But yeah, I haven't bothered
going to the institute.
Yes, we have to be very careful
whenever we say that.
It's not like I got a BA from Oxford
or something like that.
We have not, in most cases,
have been tested.
It's just a handy way,
it's something a lot of people understand.
To me, B2 is what I call fluency,
which means I can speak comfortably.
The person listening to me
is comfortable listening to me.
We communicate, I make mistakes,
I understand most things.
To me, that's kind of the functional goal
when I go to learn a language.
But very often, I don't achieve that,
I may never get there,
but it doesn't take away from my
enjoyment of discovering the language.
And I think people listening to you
or even to me might say,
"Geez, I could never learn
so many languages."
I think it's a matter of-
Once you start doing it, you discover
one language helps you learn another.
I think a lot of people are-
You know, potentially,
if that was their hobby like it is for us,
they're capable of learning
many languages.
But most people struggle with even one.
And I think most of the advice you give
at your channel, if I'm not mistaken,
is for Portuguese speakers,
and potentially speakers
of other languages,
how they can learn English better.
Because that's the one most people
are trying to learn.
And a lot of those techniques we use
for learning a variety of languages
apply just as well for people
who are trying to learn one language.
While we are on the subject
of maintaining different languages,
let's switch to Portuguese,
but let's just keep going.
Okay, that's good.
And it's a language that I never used,
a language that I never really got
that good a grasp on,
because my Spanish interferes.
But I don't worry about it.
People understand me, I understand them.
[Portuguese] Good morning, everyone.
Today, I will be speaking in Portuguese
with my guest-
Do you say "invitado" for "guest"
in Portuguese?
How do you say, "guest"?
I forgot, my-
- My friend, Gabriel.
- My friend.
He's a great Brazilian polyglot
who can speak-
Not more languages than I can.
No.
And he likes to learn languages,
he's always learning new languages
with great enthusiasm.
Today, we'll be talking about-
And I will leave a, how do you say,
a "link" or an "enlace"?
We say "a link."
A link to Gabriel's channel.
I want to talk about this concept
of learning the basic things in a language,
and how can we learn to master
the basic things in a language,
and up to what extent is this concept
of mastering the basics is realistic.
First of all, I just remembered
the word we forgot.
I sometimes forget Portuguese words, too.
It's "Convidado."
- I'm forgetting all about Portuguese.
- I forgot it, too. But it's fine.
Yes, Steve.
I think it's a very interesting subject.
Especially because,
just like we talked about many times,
far too often, there is a large focus
in learning the basics
in lessons or certain language courses,
especially the more traditional ones.
So, what can we really do to
master the basics of a language
or skip the basics altogether?
Especially because, just like we said-
If we're learning,
"Names of bathroom items."
"Names of the colors in a language."
"Names of vegetables in grocery stores."
"Names of animals in the zoo"
and such, right?
So, personally, I think-
I myself sometimes use
a stronger word for a few things.
I usually say a high vocabulary for a low
frequency is useless in the beginning.
Unless-
Unless we really have
a specific use for it, right?
If we want to use, for example,
what I just mentioned.
Really, if you work at a zoo
and you work a lot with certain animals,
you would need to use that vocabulary,
there's no helping it.
If you work at an airport,
you would have to talk-
You would probably have a conversation
at the customs, I don't know.
But I think it's very important
to learn things in context.
Right?
Exactly, but there are a few basic things
that are really basic,
but really hard to learn.
You still need a lot of time
to assimilate these things.
But there are also things
that are not as basic.
Like, for instance, those bathroom items.
The fruits in a grocery story and all that,
the name of the colors.
Things that are easy for people
who write books about language learning,
that are easy for teachers,
but that are not basic.
The names of the colors, the numbers,
those aren't basic.
And these are things, just like you said,
that you learn through context,
context we hope is interesting, right?
So, far too often, the students,
the people who learn languages,
they get frustrated,
because they forget about the basic things.
I always tell them, "That's normal."
"You will keep forgetting these things."
"And only after much time has passed,
your brain will gradually
get used to these things."
So, the concept of mastering or learning,
deliberately learning the basic things,
is a concept that's wrong
in language learning.
Yes, no doubt.
I think that's a very important message.
Because I think many students won't even
necessarily understand that initially.
Because usually, when I-
For example, let's suppose I say,
"We'll learn the Passé composé in French."
"So, let's hammer that down in our heads,
'je suis allé', 'nous sommes allés',
'j’ai été', which is what we use.
Let's keep hammering that down."
Just like you said, deliberately learning
isn't going to be extremely effective.
We're going to make 300 mistakes,
we'll forget all about the verb être
or the verb avoir, we'll forget.
We'll forget about the conjugation,
and we'll get upset.
Only through a huge level of exposure,
and only by making mistakes
and hearing the correct form,
is that we'll gradually start to really
assimilate and master this-
This thing we're learning.
But what I think is most interesting
as well is that-
Okay, maybe we can be introduced to it,
maybe someone can explain it to us,
"Look, this is how it works."
And we can even do some grammar exercises
or something like that,
if the person wants to.
However, in order for us
to really put that in practice,
we'll need a huge level of exposure.
Well, for example,
it's also interesting that, everyone-
Someone who speaks English
as their mother tongue.
The order of the adjectives,
I think it's very interesting,
because people aren't even aware of it.
For instance, if someone says,
"That is a big black shoe."
If someone says that in reverse,
"Black big shoe."
That will sound really strange
to a native speaker.
And many native speakers won't even know
why does that sound so strange.
They will correct you, they'll tell you,
"No, it's 'big black shoe.'"
What I mean is,
everyone is already teaching that.
You'll have to hammer that order down.
"No, first of all comes the color,
then it has to be this, then it's that."
And really, with a high level of exposure,
after hearing it so many times, so often,
that's when we'll naturally start to know
what is the correct order of everything.
- What do you think, Steve?
- Exactly.
Exactly, these things about conjugation
exist in several different languages.
So, it's very-
For a person who speaks English
as their mother tongue,
it will be very difficult to learn
this concept of conjugation.
And there's also gendered words, right?
Is it "gênero", male and female?
If you try to learn the rules,
"Which words are female
and which words are male?"
That's very, very difficult.
Only through a lot, but a lot of exposure.
A lot of- How do you say it?
A lot of reading and listening,
is that the brain will get used to it.
So, yes.
Is it possible? Maybe.
There's nothing wrong with reading
an explanation about the grammar,
but that won't guarantee
that you will learn those things.
Only through continuous reading,
continuous use in conversations,
continuous listening to what the other
person with whom you're talking is saying-
Gradually, it's a slow progress.
But you need to have faith in your brain,
which, with enough input,
as we call it in English-
The brain can't make
our minds want to learn.
The brain is a learning machine,
but that's a slow, slow process.
Slow, slow, slow.
So, we don't need to get frustrated
because we forgot about the basics,
because we can't make a conjugation
in a language like Portuguese or French,
because we don't know the gendered words,
because we keep making mistakes.
Making mistakes and all that is normal,
that's part of the learning process.
Undoubtedly.
This reminds me of something very-
I'll mention really quick
something you mentioned
in a video about Stephen Krashen's
theories, I believe.
- About the order of-
- The great mentor.
And something that fascinates me a lot is,
logically, how many students expect
that there is a logical order of things
that we need to learn in a language.
And now, something that-
Far too often, what'll happen is,
he has a theory about
the existence of a natural order
that we can't force, nor change.
And something that fascinates me is,
for instance,
English students often learn
Gerunds on a continuum.
For example,
"I am going, am doing something."
And that's a much more complex concept
than a simple conjugation of verb "to do."
For example,
"I do, you do, they do, he does."
And look, for instance,
I know many students and Brazilian friends,
and even people who have lived in Canada
or the United States for years,
who get this basic conjugation wrong,
"He do" or "They does."
Don't know, something like that.
And I mean, it's something that'll take
longer than some more simple concepts.
So, it's something we can't force on them.
Only through a lot of exposure
is that we'll be able to absorb that.
Right, yes.
And so, the conclusion is that
we need to keep at it, keep studying
and enjoying the learning process
without doubting yourself.
How do you say that in your language?
"Sem duvidar."
Yes, without doubting yourself.
And speaking while making mistakes
isn't a huge deal.
The most important is understanding
and continuing to speak.
And gradually, you'll get better at it.
Undoubtedly.
Well, let's stop it here.
And thank you very much,
it's always a big pleasure for me, Gabriel.
And as we say in Spanish,
"Mucha suerte."
Thank you very much, Steve.
It's always a pleasure talking with you.
- A big hug.
- See you soon.